es un mundo tranquilo donde todos están
ocupados con sus teléfonos sin embargo
los surcoreanos se observan entre sí y
no dudan en señalar a los pasajeros que
nos llevan y llevan mal el tapabocas
entre semana son 500 denuncias diarias
en el metro de seúl incluyendo 200 a
través de una aplicación creada por las
autoridades aquí tenemos un botón nada
muy sensible que parece una alarma para
señalar presión este es el número del
vagón esta es la línea la persona no
tiene máscara presionamos aquí luego
validamos todo esta geolocalizado lo que
permite señalar rápidamente a una
persona a los oficiales son éste
expatriado francés nunca ha usado la
aplicación tan popular es algo muy bueno
pero sería muy mal visto en francia para
denunciar a la gente mientras que en
corea es bastante normal una vez hecha
la denuncia los oficiales del metro
intervienen en pocos minutos desde
finales de noviembre 250 de ellos han
estado patrullando los vagones en
búsqueda de tapabocas no aprobados o de
narices que sobresalen unos días señoras
gracias
la mayoría de las veces basta con una
simple advertencia
los que se resisten pueden ser multados
con ochenta euros estas denuncias a
veces dan lugar a disputas
ah
a veces los pasajeros se enfadan dicen
malas palabras
es realmente frustrante para nosotros
me gustaría que supieran que no lo
hacemos contra ellos sino por su bien
en general esta campaña de denuncia es
bien recibida en este país donde el
interés común siempre ha primado sobre
las libertades individuales
conozco de esta aplicación y ya ha
denunciado a alguien
no me molesta en absoluto que me vigilen
e informan de mi comportamiento sólo hay
cosas buenas en este sistema
pero no muerto
en nuestra
todos tenemos que tener mucho cuidado
con el kobe 19 porque es un virus muy
contagioso y es muy peligroso para los
mayores
de marzo a noviembre hubo menos de 500
nuevos casos al día en corea del sur el
país uno de los primeros afectados en
febrero había logrado contener la
epidemia gracias a su población que no
ha bajado la guardia y a su gobierno que
se ha estado preparando desde hace
tiempo para lo peor como estas unidades
de cuidados intensivos en contenedores
fuera de los hospitales cuestan un 30%
menos y se entregan listas para
compensar la falta de espacio innovación
tecnológica y digital como el escaneo de
teléfonos obligatorio en la entrada de
bares restaurantes o lugares culturales
ese intercambio de datos permite a las
autoridades llevar a cabo una
investigación exhaustiva de cada nuevo
caso y advertir a las personas que
puedan haberse cruzado en su camino
muchos clientes están preocupados por la
seguridad de sus datos personales pero
este sistema de código qr si bien es no
tenemos forma de acceder a estos datos
serían directamente a las autoridades
hoy en día la mayoría de surcoreanos ven
esa transmisión de datos no como un
peligro sino como un progreso una forma
de ayudar a un estado en el que confían
al principio de la pandemia de escribir
nuestros datos personales a mano nuestro
nombre de nuestro contacto teníamos que
tomar el bolígrafo que todos tocamos no
era muy genio que aunque fue a limitar
el contacto humano es también el
objetivo de este pequeño robot
domiciliario que está causando furor en
uno de los edificios de un barrio de
seúl para esta madre de dos niños
pequeños es a la vez conveniente y más
seguro ella ordena por internet y ese
pequeño robot le trae sus comidas en 15
minutos
quiero para recoger el plato hay que
hacer clic en abrir la puerta es muy
sencillo solo tenemos que tomar el plato
el robot entrega el plato en la puerta
principal del edificio en medio de una
crisis de salud uno se siente mucho más
seguro o con pero al mismo tiempo es
triste porque significa que cada vez
habrá menos espacio para el contacto
humano
un total de cinco robots ahora pueden
hacer entregas a un poco más de mil
familias en un solo conjunto de
edificios
a principios de 2022 podrán tomar el
ascensor y llegar a la puerta de los
apartamentos